good morning John it's Thursday we've
been talking a lot about balloon boy and
I kind of wanted to point out to
everyone that this is really nothing new
it's fun to say that this entire balloon
boy thing it's a symptom of the messed
up world of reality television and a
faultiness of the 24-hour news cycle but
this it's nothing new it's just the way
that the world has always been news
media isn't hard to fool it's never been
hard to fool and people like to mess
with people it's not a new thing this
has been going on for a long time and
hoaxes are nothing new and so today I'm
coming to you with a list of the top 10
awesome as hoaxes of all time as picked
by me hoax number 10 I remember this one
it was like 1995 and everybody was
saying if you go outside and look at the
star tonight Mars would be as big as the
moon dude you are insane hoax number 9
back in the beginning of the existence
of photography around 1917 some girls
stole their dad's camera and took a
bunch of pictures of themselves with
cutouts of fairies from a popular fairy
book because the idea of photographs
were also new and no one ever seen a
faked photograph before everyone was
like oh my god fairies number 8 in 1995
a couple of hoodwink errs showed a bunch
of media folks up actual image on so
will alien getting actually could open
by two doctors all of those actuals are
actually fakes they did it in their
garage hoax number seven apparently I'd
ground and PO aside from being a
marvelously dark poet also was a fan of
the hoodwink he convinced a newspaper
reporter that there was a guy who had
flown over the Atlantic Ocean in a
balloon in three days and everyone was
like that's awesome that's so cool it's
not even that hard to believe though
seems to have done this just to prove
that he can pull a fast one on the world
which he did well done hoax number six
the Fiji mermaid pictured here was
thought to be an actual mermaid for many
many years and impressed millions of
spectators who paid to see it when they
finally got an actual scientist to look
at the actual mermaid it turned out that
it was a body of a baby ape sewn onto a
fish and then wrapped in paper mache one
that's pretty gross and pretty sick - an
excellent hoax 5 the Mechanical Turk in
1770 an inventor unveiled a humanoid
robot that can play chess and beat
famous people the likes of Napoleon and
Benjamin Franklin in 1770 a mechanical
robot that complete chess of course it
turned out that there was a dude inside
of the mechanical robot
hoax number for every single perpetual
motion device ever it's been going on to
the beginning of time people saying that
they can create energy where there was
no energy before and the accepting
investments on their technology hoax
number three in 1983 a German magazine
paid six million dollars for what it
thought was a 60 volume set of Hitler's
Diaries turned out though the books were
printed on modern paper written with
modern ink and were entirely
historically inaccurate the forger /
hoaxster was sentenced to 42 months in
prison number two in 1835 the new york
sun printed a six-part series by john
herschel the most respected astronomer
of the times about the race of people on
the moon the goats and the bison there
and the winged beasts that bathed in the
rivers John Herschel in fact read it and
thought that it was hilarious the rest
of the world though was captivated by
this vision of the moon people believed
that for like six straight weeks there
were other newspapers reporting that
they were all angry at the Sun for
getting the scoop on this moon story and
the Sun subscriptions went way up and
they stayed way up establishing it as a
permanent fixture in New York and hoax
number one possibly the greatest hoax
ever perpetrated was in fact probably an
accident the War of the Worlds HG
Wells's famous fictional radio broadcast
was so lifelike and contained so many
actual real sounding news reporters and
a guy whose that'd just like the
president telling everybody not to panic
that people actually thought that they
could smell the poison gas from the
Martians and saw flashes off in the
distance toward New Jersey a rebroadcast
a translation in Ecuador actually
resulted in the deaths of 20 people it
all goes to show you
we're not that hard to fool I think that
we should probably just accept that and
trust people anyway